this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck enjoy the
show every little thing you think that's
me every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
everybody this is Joshua fields
Melbourne and this is Ryan Nicodemus we
are that way oh no we're the minimalist
we are the minimalist great this is our
very first ever podcast and we've
already screwed up I know during the
intro man we just lost like 20 listeners
well hey everyone welcome aboard this is
our very first ever podcast today we
have a a studio audience with us of
three our producer Sean and then we have
Mariah and Becks here as well so if you
hear laughter in the background it's
because we have paid them to laugh at
our jokes so well let's talk about why
we decided to do this podcast in the
first place we've been doing this whole
minimalists thing for the past five
years now and we've written a ton of
books and essays but we hit the road
quite a bit and we've done hundreds of
events and our favorite part from a lot
of these events is at the end we tend to
do a Q&A session questions and attempted
answers and this is our attempt to do
that without going on the road for 10
months a year as we've done in the past
and going to hundreds of cities which is
great and we'll still be doing that but
this is an opportunity to do that even
while we are home so our podcast is
going to be formatted basically as a
huge question answer conversation
between Ryan and myself and of course
you the listener so we'll go ahead and
get started with our very first segment
which is a minimal monologue
and the rant that I have this week is
well we had a contest for our book
everything that remains up on Instagram
and we asked people to answer a question
for us which we attempted to answer
actually with that book and that
question is what is one thing you always
thought you wanted but then once you got
it you no longer wanted it and we wanted
to announce the winners of that contest
today I would encourage you to go and
check out the hundreds of comments on
Instagram we also posted it on Facebook
as well
and see there's just a ton of
inspirational comments from people who
had attained something had achieved
something that they well had always
wanted and realized once they got it it
didn't make them happy didn't make them
satisfied they didn't feel fulfilled by
it so Ryan you want to read some of some
of the winners here yeah so the first
winner is hailey Adams
she said I always wanted some I always
wanted
some day I couldn't wait for my husband
to finish grad school or have a second
child now I'm realizing that it's the
little moments of every day
that make me happy so I'm learning to
enjoy the now and realizing it's a
pretty great place to be you know that
reminded me of an essay that we have on
on our website called someday we are
constantly searching for this this thing
and so Ryan I put together an exercise
to try to make some day today olá just
read a quick snippet from it ryan hates
when i read essays so i'm going to read
an essay now so this essay is on our
website the minimalist calm slash some
day but you can also find it in the show
notes for this episode along with
everything else we mentioned in this
episode the essay goes like this let's
go analog for a moment grab a pen and a
piece of paper and write down a handful
of meaningful things you've been
intending to do label this list some day
here's some examples that we have
declutter your home read a classic novel
take a road trip get into shape during a
yoga class learn how to meditate start a
new business play an instrument
contribute to your community fall in
love now on the back of the same sheet
of paper list every action that has
occupied the last 24 hours of your life
label this list today and some examples
there might be shopping busy work
attending meetings checking email
perusing social media sitting in traffic
working late again hitting the snooze
button thumbing through useless apps
sharing passive I'm sorry staring
passively at a glowing screen and while
many of the items in the second lists
are necessary or even urgent but just
because something is urgent doesn't mean
it's worthwhile in fact
misguided urgency is often the enemy of
progress and for most of us some day is
the single most dangerous word we utter
it grants us the illusion of future
possibility without having to focus on
that which is important today
just imagine though how different your
life would be if you switched your list
titles or if you flip the page and made
some day today are worse what if what if
you wait years from now you might be
singing around pining for some day to
arrive someday yeah it's funny uh I was
thinking about while you reading that
about how I have really been getting out
of my workout routine lately and it was
like Tuesday I was like oh yeah the new
years growing around I'm gonna get back
into it
and all of a sudden I'm like no like I'm
gonna do it now I'm gonna I'm gonna go
to the gym I'm just going to run for a
half hour maybe it's not like the exact
routine that I that I want to do but I
can at least do something and get in
there and get some work done and not be
that guy who's strong
that you know on January 1st starting a
routine and just let it go but yet it's
a it's important to take action for sure
quite often our affinity for perfection
or getting it just right prohibits us
from actually doing it so having the
right workout clothes the membership to
the right gym the right time of day the
right minds mindset the right music
playing whatever it may be and we have
all these rules we set up that actually
prevent us from accomplishing what we
want to accomplish yeah definitely
because our next winner our next winner
is Kelly Mills
Kelly Mills Road I wanted a Keurig for a
time when everyone was getting one now
if for those of you who have been living
on Mars a Keurig is a really overly
priced coffee maker which Ryan and I
have both owned in the past so I want to
be sure I in fact I've owned several
because they've broken or some of the
retail stores we used to manage back in
the day actually had them if you
remember some of the stores you manage
today yeah they had a Keurig for
customer customers yeah yeah it's like a
single cup coffee serving type machine I
resisted for a long time she writes
reminding myself that the small cups are
wasteful and pricey then we got one as a
gift and we loved it for a time then we
noticed the cake ups were wasteful and
pricey which we already knew beforehand
and we got rid of it so I'm going to
pause for a second cake ups that is the
the little individual packet that goes
in the Machine and the piece of plastic
that holds the 'el tablespoons of coffee
right yeah the creator of the cake up
has expressed his regrets as well
ultimately we are drawn in by
convenience without considering the real
cost of it all in the grand scheme of
all the things well since we're talking
about coffee we might as well at least
bring this up later in in January we're
going to be in st. Petersburg for three
days what we're calling three
caffeinated days with the minimalists
Ryan and I was our initial intention
after we after we left the corporate
world to sort of just become baristas
and live a pretty simple life that way
and we're finally getting to live our
dream at least for three days down in
st. Petersburg Florida our friends
Joshua and Sara who actually do
photography for our website they live
down there and they're opening an
awesome very well curated coffee shop
called bandit coffee now we're screening
our documentary which comes out in May
but we're going to do a special charity
screening there unfortunately for you
that is already sold out but don't fret
if you're anywhere in Florida or even
Georgia I'm sure we'll have some people
drive from different places in the south
you you can still come hang out with us
for a couple days and we'll make some
coffee for you at bandit coffee if you
want some information on that it's just
bandit coffee dot Co bandit coffee Co
slash minimalists and again we'll put
that as well as everything else in the
show notes also if you like work guess
we're really big proponents of drinking
great coffee and I would tell you the
one thing about the Keurig is it's
convenient but it's shitty coffee it is
it's like this wonderful convenient
machine that produces mediocre coffee
yea and mediocre if if you get a good
cup of it I mean in general I wouldn't
drink a cup of Keurig coffee now it
there's no intention behind it it's not
very deliberate it's it's a quick fix it
is easy but it is not simple it's not
beautiful it's it's not meaningful and
so if you want to see our coffee setup
while we're on the road we we did this
last year we were recording a
documentary and our director Matt did a
video called pack like the minimalists
and you can see how we packed we were on
the road for four ten months in 2014
actually and we each packed one duffel
bag and we also had a coffee kit with us
as well because we're over coffee good
yeah it's really hard to get to get good
coffee in certain places especially like
Saskatchewan and and so we we have our
own coffee kit so you can find that at
the minimalists comm slash pack and I
think the last thing for for Kelly here
we'll send her a copy of of the book
obviously but we also wrote an essay
called
life is an acquired taste and you can
find that at our website the minimalists
comm slash coffee where we just talked
about using coffee as a metaphor and
sort of why we tend to drink black
coffee as opposed to coffee with Splenda
and and I don't sprinkles or whatever
people put in their coffee now it
doesn't mean that's inherently wrong but
there there are reasons to enjoy the
simpler version of things Coffee
sprinkles patent-pending and I just want
to say to all the folks out there who
have a Keurig and love it I'm glad that
you love your Keurig it just does not
add value to either of our lives and
you're killing the planet who's the next
winner the next winner Erin Frizzle am I
saying that right yes you don't ever
question it just read the name however
you sow so like I would just read this
and say Erin Crizal says oh yeah I'm
probably totally wrong I like it sorry
Erin or a wren Erin Crizal writes a
partner so keep in mind they're asking
we're asking what is one thing you've
always wanted you always thought you
wanted but then once you got it you no
longer wanted it a partner though I have
not always felt that I could find
happiness through relationship marriage
and the like I have spent a significant
number of years building one a shared
life with a single individual it became
stifling to try to rectify the disparity
between what I wanted for myself and my
intent to let to live mindfully with
their expectations for our life together
I realized through time and much
self-reflection that what I want most of
all is an intentional life alone rather
than an unintentional life one together
okay so so you know it's it's
interesting here's what I'll say is
relationships are our relationships
whether they're intimate in terms of
having a partner or friendships or
whatever it's one of the most important
values in in my life and so so Erin
we're going to we'll send you a copy of
everything that remains
because that was part of the contest but
I'm going to send you to other books
that are gonna at least point you in the
direction of what a meaningful
relationship is I think you're right you
shouldn't have to depend on any one
person to make you happy you yourself
are a complete person and so my friend
Colin right our friend Colin right
recently wrote a book called some
thoughts about relationships and it's a
phenomenal book and in fact my partner
who's here in our studio audience right
now and I literally have sat down and
read it page 4 page of these little
musings on different parts of a
relationship what he calls rules so he
has different rules that are very
pliable you're able to to bend them to
fit your lifestyle and here's the truth
you know you don't need to be a partner
to be complete but our relationships are
a very important part of our lives and
the nice thing is we get to define what
that means whether you have a partner or
whether you have whether you're by
yourself you're still going to have
other people in your life life isn't
worth living without other people and
the other book we're going to send you
while we're sending those is our very
first book which is a book called
minimalism live a meaningful life
there's an entire chapter about
relationships in there and sort of how
how do we go about reprioritizing our
relationships which I think most of us
don't do for the most part a lot of us
create relationships based on proximity
and convenience and so we spend most of
our time with coworkers or networking
buddies or people that are fine people
but they aren't the most important
people in our lives and there are ways
that we can reprioritize those those
relationships and actually allocate our
time which is and our attention our two
most precious resources on the people
who are most important to us now that's
a great point um yeah let's listen to
the voicemail question from Elizabeth hi
Josh hi I'm Ryan it's um Elizabeth um or
tee Schwartz and I'm calling from
Connecticut and my question for the
podcast is to
any recommendations for people who are
undergoing cluttering that it's not a
packing party something a little bit
more gradual you know I think that my
frustration is that things they're going
and moving but it's taking too long with
some of the other things that are going
on my life so I'd like to you know to
spark up the process and move it along a
little bit more so if you have any
specific recommendations for that I
would be happy to hear them thank you so
much for doing what you do to help
people live less cluttered life Thanks
bye all right so it basically sounds to
me like what Elizabeth's question is is
how do you gradually declutter your home
mm-hmm there's a few different ways to
do this right I mean you could do what I
did you could have a packing party
although she specifically said in the
voice ma she did not want to have a
packing party but for those listeners
out there who would be able to do
something like that that is certainly uh
I don't want to say a quick and easy way
because there's nothing easy about it
but for me going through that three-week
experiment it was a long enough time to
to really understand what was and wasn't
adding value to my life but yeah
certainly there are families and other
people out there who have a ton of stuff
and a packing party would be an absolute
nightmare so yeah and we've had a lot of
readers who have done your packing party
but for one room in their house - we get
a lot of people who say you know what
you did is too extreme so I'm just going
to do a easier version of it I would
actually argue that the packing party is
probably the simplest way to do things
because it's a cinch that set of rules
that you set up for yourself and you
follow in a very quick period of time
but it doesn't because it's simple
doesn't mean it's easy it's a fairly
difficult task but once you get through
it you're you're much better off yeah
and you know I know readers who have
done that with one room to then move on
to the rest of their house or to move on
to other rooms and yeah just doing that
one piece at a time
every three weeks or every four weeks
going through and and really putting
everything together and figuring out
what you're using what you're not using
certainly there's the also the
minimalism game that tens of thousands
of our readers have really got a ton of
value out of where you can find your
friend or family member who wants to
declutter and you can kind of make this
active decluttering turn it from a banal
action into something fun and a little
bit competitive where you on the first
day of the month you both agree to get
rid of one item and then on the second
day of the month you get rid of two
items and then the third day of the
month three items so on and so forth and
whoever makes it to the end of the month
wins so you know if you guys bet a
dinner or if you if you bet something
small a movie or something like that
that can certainly be worth all that
effort and then if both people make it
they both win right you know totally and
it makes them a lot you win really
because it's a lot more fun decluttering
is boring and I hear the word
decluttering I just sort of went because
it's like why would I want to just clean
out my closet or like it's so boring I
understand the benefits of it
intellectually but emotionally it's a
little bit harder to follow and I think
by having an accountability partner
there you're really going to be able to
get not just get the momentum you need
but but stay accountable and continue to
move forward so you can find really an
accountability partner anywhere it could
be a spouse family member friend
co-worker enemy who will keep you
accountable but also if you don't have
anyone who will be supportive view of
you in that fashion you can go to our
online community over at minimalist org
and we have free local meetup groups in
a hundred cities now and if you're in if
you're near one of those hundred cities
you can actually meet with people online
and in person with the monthly meetups
or if you're not near one of those those
cities and you're in a different country
we have those in eight countries by the
way you can connect with our online city
so just go to minimalist org find your
city or connect with folks in an online
city and they'll help keep you they'll
help keep you accountable the last thing
I'd recommend for
or Elizabeth is the practical minimalism
tips that we have on our website so we
did something called a 30 days or I'm
sorry a month of minimalism and so you
can go to the minimalists comm slash
month and there are some pretty
practical tips we took some beautiful
photographs and put them up on Instagram
and they wrote a caption with each one
of those photos just giving some very
practical tips about junk drawers and
about experiences and about living rooms
lie all of these different practical
tips that by themselves are fairly easy
but when you add it up a bunch of easy
things you've all of a sudden
decluttered your home and gotten the
excess out now let's keep in mind while
we're doing this though you're you're
getting the access out of the way to
make room for what's truly important you
could go get rid of all your stuff and
still be utterly miserable come home to
an empty house and sulk after removing
all your pacifiers that's not the point
of minimalism the point of metaphor
minimalism is getting that excess out of
the way
finding what truly adds value to your
life what brings you joy and then
finding out what's important outside of
the stuff so you're able to start reply
replacing the stuff the time you
allocated to the stuff to your health to
your relationships to your passions and
to growth and contribution and those
five things are the five values we wrote
about in our book minimalism love a
meaningful life so Elizabeth I'm going
to send you a copy of that as well I
hope you find value in it
yeah I think the the last last thing I
would add to this is to just really get
clear on why you want to declutter I
mean that is really what is going to
drive you it's what's going to motivate
you to to take these daily actions to
make these small steps and that could be
the simple reason of oh I want to have
you know come or company over more room
for company or I want to clean my house
and half the time of what it takes now
or or maybe it's it's just the aesthetic
you just want to have a nice clean clear
home but whatever those reasons are make
sure you're clear on those and you are
focusing on on the wine yeah for us it
comes onto the
five things and and really helps us stay
motivated Elizabeth thank you for your
question and we're going to move on to
some questions from social media this is
our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round so a lot of you have
posted questions on social media we'll
get through some of those on this
podcast on Twitter
Virginie ji asks how do you explain
greed in our society is greed
distinguished as capitalism or
enlightened self-interest you know their
isolation Panzi study it's interesting
because you are primates chimpanzees you
also can look at bonobos and they're
they're both radically different chimps
tend to hoard stuff it's a psychological
imperative for them or maybe just an
evolutionary imperative if you give them
you know a hoard of bananas they will
fight off other chimpanzees to try to
hold on to them bonobos tend to share
the same hoard and now I don't know
whether or not we're more like chimps or
bonobos in that respect it's probably
little bit of both depending on on the
individual but I would say capitalism
which you mentioned here Virginie
doesn't necessarily lead to greed
capitalism itself isn't inherently bad I
would actually argue the system that we
have right now is in capitalism it's
crony capitalism you look at the most
affluent people they have the most
influence on the political process
look at the people who donate the most
money to political action committees
especially after 2010 with the Supreme
Court decision on corporations are
basically people and and the money that
is in politics now has tipped the scales
toward the most affluent people in the
country the four hundred most affluent
people in the country I'll give you a
quick stat during Bill Clinton while he
was running for president
33 million dollars running for president
a lot of money except in the 2016
election the person who wins is going to
spend about two billion dollars I mean
it's not even close in terms of order of
magnitude and that's because of the
money that is now in politics that's not
capitalism that's not a meritocracy that
is a rigged system you know the system
isn't broken it's fixed and and so if I
were to look at the problem I wouldn't
say no it's not capitalism greed is is a
result of unfriendly competition there
are some American Indian tribes who
think of competition as a mental illness
and while I certainly wouldn't go that
far I think friendly competition is okay
but when it's winner take all in
survival situations whether that's food
or resources or homes or money etc then
we we start to face some pretty
difficult problems and the way to change
that really isn't at a expecting the
government to to fix everything the way
to change that is for us to fix it at a
relatively local level and then it
spreads to a more a more nationwide
level I think if you look at some of the
problems that we've had now like
marriage equality so with gay marriage
or even with with marijuana legalization
those are things that have been bottle
necked in the federal government for
many many decades but when it started to
happen on a local level
it's snowballed and then you start to
see states passed and all of a sudden
enough states and municipalities pass
certain laws then you start to see on a
regional or even national or worldwide
level it becomes rapidly more accepted
than it was even a decade prior yeah I
mean you just say that makes me think of
how these sharing economies are starting
to pop up here and there I mean and
somewhere in Connecticut I just saw they
just opened up their first stuff library
that's awesome so it's just a bunch of
stuff where you go there you you can
borrow a tool you can borrow whatever
they have it there's
it's not like anything specific it's
it's they just have a bunch of stuff
yeah it's uh we have a guy in in
Albuquerque who came up to us and said I
use Craigslist as my storage locker so
when I need a chainsaw I go to
Craigslist and get my chainsaw and then
when I'm done with with that chainsaw I
put it back in my storage locker
craigslist let someone else give value
from it so there are a bunch of
different things that'll allow us to
have access to things without having to
incessantly hoard those items in
perpetuity
our next lightning round question is
from Palma Thani on Facebook Ryan Palma
Thani asks what do you do with the old
photos after you scan them I can't bring
myself to throw them away or shred them
especially the ones with my parents in
them I feel so cruel and ungrateful if I
do that get rid of them just AG
minimalism yeah next well they're
talking about an essay if you go to our
website the minimalist com ford slash
scanning where we had a scanning party
with our photos where we scanned
everything uploaded them online up to
the magical cloud backed him up on our
computers and then we threw the photos
away which certainly wasn't the easiest
thing ever
I know that when I was first starting to
get rid of them it was this this tearing
of my heart when I was dropping the box
of this box of photos into the trash and
and I kind of hesitated I'm like nah
your minimalist you got to do this and
and I couldn't bring myself to throw the
whole box away so what I did is I just
picked a couple pictures out and put
them in the trash can and then thought
alright I'm going to sleep on it see how
I feel in the morning I got up went to
work didn't even think about it till I
got home actually and realized that you
know the memories are not in the
pictures the memories are not in those
physical pictures they can certainly
trigger a lot of memories but letting
those go eventually it felt felt really
really good there's another option too
for those out there who want to scan not
just photos but documents in general
you can send those off I think it's
$1.00 scan yeah there's there's a few
different websites out there we're not
getting any promotional money for this
but yeah just go ahead $1 scan comm
there's a couple others out there where
you can send in your photos you can send
in your paperwork they will scan
everything and the beautiful thing is is
they shred it all afterward you can't
even you can't get it back there's no
way to get it back so yeah and I think
once you look for me when my mother
passed away and I had to deal with all
of her stuff I realized some really
important lessons one of the biggest
lessons I learned is that the memories
aren't in the things the memories are
inside us although it's true what Ryan
said sometimes the things themselves can
actually trigger the memories inside us
and so before I left Florida left my
mom's apartment and a guard of a bunch
of her stuff I took pictures a lot of
her things so in those pictures along
with the foot boxes of photographs I
took back to Ohio and eventually scanned
all of those photos allowed me to let go
because I realized I wasn't letting go
of the memories that I initially thought
were inside those things the memories
are in me and now I still have the
triggers for those memories so if you
scan them there's something awesome that
happens once you scan them if you use a
digital picture frame Beks you just got
a a digital picture frame for your
parents this past Christmas we were just
out there and in Minnesota and they were
all just like all of us were gathered
around it like a warm fireplace or
something it if you just get a picture
frame and give it to someone no one pays
any attention to it if you scan a bunch
of photos and they rotate through a
picture afraid it'll picture frame
repeatedly then you you actually have
people who care about the the content
that's on them and so you can see what
picture digital picture frame that I use
at the SI that Ryan mentioned that the
scanning part ESA as well as the scanner
that we've used quite a few times the
minimalists comm / scanning Lindsay
Goodwin on Instagram asks how do you
deal with the natural pulling away from
friends with different value sets mmm
that is never easy is it I remember well
we had the same friend we've you know we
got friends that we hung out with hi in
high school we have a friend we have a
friend no I'm just thinking about I just
was what we debating whether or not I
wanted to say his name but I'm not going
to but Josh and I have a mutual friend
that we went to high school with who we
just kind of gradually drifted apart and
he never really kind of grew up and our
values changed and his didn't and that
is certainly difficult um I still will
talk to him every once in a while call
me on the phone or whatever but uh but
yeah it's it certainly is never easy to
have those conversations for me when I
was going through the vast majority of
my relationships changing when I
realized that I needed to take some
massive action and change in majority of
the people I was hanging out with I had
a lot of conversations the first
conversation I had was with my mom when
she called me up and she was like hey
how you doing son I'm doing well and
this was about a month after we had
launched the website and I'm like how
are you doing mom she's like I'm yeah I
do doing pretty good what's this
minimalist stuff and she must've like
google my name
online or something cuz but we didn't
tell anyone and I'm like oh you know mom
it's just this something I'm trying in
my life to simplify and just make make
my life a little bit more manageable
than what it is right now and just going
down this journey I really don't know
where it's going to take me but I just
know that I don't want to continue
living the life that I am I I need to
make changes and she was like well you
know I I think that's great things great
you're making changes are you gonna be
around for the holidays and I'm like
yeah of course I'm gonna be around for
the holidays mom what well why do you
think I wouldn't be around for the
holidays in fact I hope to be around
more than just the holidays I hope I
hope that I can free up some time to see
you more than where I see you now too
which is pretty much just on the
holidays and she was like alright well
that's good good to hear that um I'm
still gonna buy his stuff though just so
you know which I suppose she has the
right to do that as my mother um
and that's where I kind of pushed back a
little bit and said mom I appreciate the
sentiment I appreciate you thinking
about me but if you get me anything that
doesn't add value to my life if you get
me something that I can't use I'm gonna
have to get rid of it whether it's find
someone else who can use it or find
could give it to a goodwill or something
like that and by the way this is not the
thing to say to your mother she she got
really upset you're gonna give away my
gifts in them we kind of went back and
forth but eventually what it came down
to was me kind of just settling down a
little bit and saying mom I love you so
much you love me right she's like yeah
of course I love you son I'm like I want
you to be happy you want me to be happy
too right she's like yeah of course I
want you to be happy I was like well if
that's the case then I just need your
support I just need you to support this
journey that I'm on that doesn't mean
that you have to have a packing party it
doesn't mean that I'm going to come to
your home and judge the things in your
home it just means that I just need you
to please support me along this journey
and I had that conversation a lot and
it's not an easy conversation to have
but it certainly it certainly was a
valuable tool to to get me through those
tough times it's a great question I
spend time with far fewer people than I
used to Max and I were just listening to
a podcast Derek Siver's was talking
about just having two really awesome
people in your life and I think that's a
great tip for introverts I think it's a
terrible tip for extroverts especially
you know people who want to spend
majority of their time alone and so what
I'll tell you is my relationships look
appreciably different today compared to
what they look like back in the
corporate world when I was 27 years old
and I thought that I had to do all these
extroverted things and attend all of
these community meetings and networking
events and meetings and post meeting
meetings and pre meeting meetings and in
all of these things and it's like these
people were bad people they're fine
people that I spent most of my time with
they just didn't share my values
necessarily they didn't share my
interest or desires and now I associate
with fewer people and the best advice I
ever got is you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you really what that means is you
can't try to fix someone in your life if
their values are different from yours
that's okay but you can surround
yourself with people who do have similar
values similar interests beliefs desires
similar goals and paths that you want to
go down and you can have a well curated
life that way every Tuesday we do
something on periscope called Tuesdays
with the minimalist we're doing this
throughout January 2016 and it's a 7
p.m. Eastern time where we do a sort of
a live Q&A session with folks on on
periscope and you know hundreds or
thousands of people show up and we just
sort of answer your questions there live
on camera and it's it's really great and
we've had quite a few people every time
we're up there a they mentioned Ryan's
hair they always want him to do weird
things with his hair which is awesome
and then and then some people mention
like run especially Ryan in particular
like in order to be a minimalist Ryan do
you have to always wear a black t-shirt
enjoys right
and answers yes and you can buy the
t-shirts and jeans from our website
149 95 that's right no you you know I
think it's it's not about that I think
minimalist where they're their favorite
clothes and so we wrote an essay about
this called favorite clothes of a
minimalist which you can find at the
minimalist comm slash clothes but Ryan
do want to talk about you rob your
choice to literally wear a uniform yeah
I just wear a uniform because it's easy
to be honest but at the end of the day
the uniform that I wear I love and I
really feel good when I wear a black
t-shirt and when I wear jeans and it's
their great quality jeans great quality
shirts I'm very comfortable and I don't
I don't find myself
not that I did this all the time where I
was you know spending hours getting
ready going through clothes and trying
to find the right outfit but I don't
find myself spending nearly as much time
getting ready for sure and making you
not to make as many decisions either
right which it's a silly decision we
have to make all these little tiny
decisions so later in the day or 4 p.m.
were worn out because we've already made
the 120 decisions that we have for the
day that are good decisions why not save
it the decision on something that is
more meaningful yeah but I'll tell you
what I love well I'll tell you what I
hated and this does not happen anymore
when I would go to my closet and I pull
out a shirt and I'm like man I really
love that shirt
but it doesn't really look that good on
me maybe I needed to like lose a little
weight or maybe I needed to gain a
little weight just it didn't look right
on me and then I would put it back on my
closet and be like one day one day
that's going to fit and when I went
through my packing party I just remember
getting rid of so many clothes with that
head tag still on them and all those
some day shirts but I do not experience
that anymore which is which is awesome
and my hair well it's just fabulous
that's it's just kind of how it works oh
shoot no I I appreciate all the
compliments on periscope that's great
Feli vee asks on youtube this is on our
youtube channel which we just did a
bunch of rearranging so you can check
out a bunch of excerpts from our
documentary on there and fella is
actually asking about the documentary
they said when is your movie coming out
and it'll be in theaters in the United
States and Canada hopefully about four
hundred cities we signed a distribution
deal last year with a unique distributor
and more details come in on that you can
actually help us get the documentary to
your city we'll have a lot of
information on that but it's going to
come out May 24 2016 were really excited
about it we spent the last two years
working on this interviewing minimalist
from all different walks of life
minimalist families minimalist
entrepreneurs and librarians and
musicians yeah all of these different
people who use minimalism to simplify
their life so they can figure out and
and focus on what they care about most
and so that would be in theaters May
24th we're looking forward to sharing
with you and also Ryan and I are going
to go to 12 and a half cities and screen
this documentary right before it
actually comes out in theatres so you
can take place in that as well
details are coming on that very soon
stay tuned to the film's website which
is minimalism film calm or you can just
subscribe to our website the minimalists
calms enter your email there and we'll
make sure we keep you posted on that and
of course will never ever ever send you
spam because spam is yucky and that
brings us to the Pinterest question from
Bridget Elizabeth where we had posted
something about this campaign in
Honduras and she wrote about or she
wrote this this pin doesn't link back to
anywhere can you edit the source source
to link to the site where we can donate
so yes we will absolutely update that
link and for anyone out there who is in
a giving mood we could certainly use
your help too at the minimalists com
forward slash hope if you want to
contribute to that orphanage I'd figured
out how to use Pinterest recently it
turns out we have a lot of people who
follow us on Pinterest we post our
essays and also some beautiful
architecture on there occasionally we
don't really use it that much but we
find a lot of people do get value in it
and we posted a photo of us Ryan and
myself signing 1400 copies of everything
that remained so it was this mountain of
books of everything that remains we were
signing those for charity we actually
asked people to donate to a campaign so
last year 2015 was a year of
contribution for the minimalists and
thank you for giving us the opportunity
not to just contribute to you all with
our essays and books and everything else
and now with this podcast which is
awesome but also contribute to the world
around us and so we did four different
things last year we we built some some
clean water wells in Malawi a village
there that was for my birthday campaign
the prayer
a year but the money got allocated last
year so we were able to make that
contribution we built a Elementary
School and Laos and Ryan just went over
there for the grand opening of that and
thanks to you we were able to raise
enough money to literally build an
entire school that's like the most
amazing donation the fundraising thing
I've ever been part of and it happened
so quick it was like we got the money in
February gave it to Tyson and they had
the school built by by the time I got
out there in October which was which was
really cool yeah it was amazing and we
actually raised so much money from that
campaign we took the proceeds there was
a needy high school in Uganda and we
partnered with our friends over at a
misfit conference and in Fargo North
Dakota and they helped us fund a high
school for an entire year in Uganda with
the with the extra money we made there
so and it's not just fun the high school
but it's fun some really amazing
programs that makes the high school more
sustainable it gives some education to
mothers in the community and allows them
to make micro businesses that allow them
to to also bring money back into the
school but also provide for their
student for their kids the school
supplies and everything else and the
last thing we did or actually in the
process of doing is building a
family-style orphanage in Honduras we
partnered with our friend Joshua Becker
and his nonprofit which is called the
hope effect and we're building a
family-style war orphanage there in
Honduras and you can still contribute to
that until the end of January 2016 if
you're interested in helping us build
that orphanage at the minimalists comm
slash hope we have a question from
Google Plus now here's a weird thing
about Google Plus we literally have
hundreds of thousands of followers on
Google+ and we did nothing to deserve
that and so I'm not really sure why I
paid them all a dollar no I split one
dollar between all of them you know I we
we had a someone Adam
we wrote an essay and Adam Jones
question to that essay was so you don't
gain any money from your website at all
and the essay was about support the
minimalists and so last year back in
2015 we got an email and actually had a
call with some folks at Google about
advertising with them and it was
interesting because I'm like do they
want us to do some sort of AdWords
campaign that we don't generally do
advertisements but someone from Google
calls you you you tend to call them back
and so we we set up a meeting and I met
with the gentleman from Google and he
was really really nice but he wanted us
to place advertisements on our site and
with the stats because they had our
stats we use Google Analytics on our
site we would make roughly ten thousand
dollars a month from advertisements
which is six figures a year it's pretty
amazing from just placing a few banner
ads on your website Josh if we could
just make six figures a year we'll be
happy you know and and we tend not to
let money dictate how we make our
decisions and it's been great to be able
to say that all along give lip service
to that like yeah we're not allergic to
money but we're not going to let money
run our lives but then when someone
shows up it says here's a huge bag of
money all you have to do is put some ads
on your site and we ended up saying no
to that not because we think
advertisements are inherently evil or
bad I mean I think advertisements suck
generally and and I like avoiding them
and so they're kind of against our
values and so we didn't want to
compromise our values for the sake of
money and we've had several people yell
at us for this and say you could have
given that money to charity and it's
like well but yeah but it's not part of
my values robbing a bank isn't part of
my values either but if I rob the bank
he gave it all to charity that wouldn't
make it right and so you we decided not
to put advertisements on our site and a
way to supplement for that as we gave
people the opportunity to donate to our
site so we can keep it going and the
same goes with our podcast so our
website all the essays they're
completely free we do all kinds of free
stuff most of our events that we do in
person are free they're not free to us
but they're free to the attendees and
truly not even free then we still ask
for your time and your attention which
are more valuable than your money
because money is a renewable resource
but the truth is that you know
everything is is free but you can still
support it if you find value in our work
so if you find value in our podcasts and
you want to donate a dollar in episode
that goes a long way for us and helps us
produce more you can just go to the
minimalists com slash donate you can
read the whole story about why we
decided to be a hundred percent
advertisement free on our website and
also on our podcast so we're not going
to shell you know t-shirts or mattresses
or any of the other things that I hear
on the countless podcast I listen to
we're not going to bombard you with
those messages
not because they're evil but because
they go against our values and so to
answer your question Adam you don't gain
any money at all from your website well
no you can donate there and we certainly
gain money that way we also sell books
we sell books traditionally in
bookstores but also online that's
another way that we are able to earn a
living and the nice thing about being a
minimalist when you get your bills down
to such a small amount of money that you
need to live every month you can do
certain things and not require to to
continue to feed a lifestyle that won't
necessarily bring you joy or happiness
alright let's go ahead and move on to
our next segment which is reader
comments Ryan you wanna talk about
Facebook yes we had posted an essay on
Facebook and we have s it was a
minimalist family twelve useful links
yeah and we we've had this gentleman his
name is hip digs commented I agree but
my ten-year-old daughter drives me crazy
with her clutter so so what mister digs
here is is saying is that yes you can be
a minimalist family but I my daughter
prevents me from being truly a
minimalist which the only thing I would
say is tell that to Leo Bob alte our
friend leo if you go to the minimalists
comm / leo
he has six kids and he's sort of the
ultra minimalist he puts Ryan and myself
to shame when it comes to living a
minimalist lifestyle the quote that came
to mind I just posted a picture on my
personal Instagram account account the
other day was from Epictetus and it was
a picture of Rebecca and her daughter
and the quote that I added to that is
when your child I'm sorry when you call
your child be prepared that she may not
respond to you or if she does she might
not do what you want her to do under
these circumstances it doesn't help your
child for you to become agitated it
should not be in her power to cause you
any disturbance so mr. Diggs I would
encourage you to read that quote it
should not be within your child's power
to cause you any disturbance
I love the Stoics amen so Michelle on
Twitter writes Ryan should wear a man
bun but um no Mariah what do you think
yeah no she's given the throat slashing
sound I'm not sure if he means literally
she's gonna slash your throat if you
were a man bun but I'm gonna assume yes
yes I'm gonna assume that too thanks for
the suggestion so also you can write
your comments to us at our p o-- box you
can find although the p o-- box
information we get tons and tons of
letters and postcards we read every
single one of them we do our best to
respond to all of them as well it's our
preferred method of of written
communication if you're not going to
contact us in social media just go to
the minimalists comm slash contact you
can find our information for our p o--
box there and we read every single one
of those on soundcloud levi flint says
i'm so glad you guys decided to make a
pod get a podcast seriously what a great
idea
also your theme song
is awesome our theme song is awesome I
agree Peter Doran you can find more of
his music at the minimalists comm slash
Peter he wrote the theme song it's
called every little thing and if you go
to that link you can also see a video of
him performing it and it's an amazing
song when we did a tour in the UK and
the fall of 2014 he went on some of the
tour stops with us and he's such a a
talented musician and we're grateful
that he was able to let us use that song
after begging him to use it and will
continue to use it for a while it's a
phenomenal song and it fits perfectly
with our minimalist motif let's go on to
a comment from iTunes edy han says what
is great about these two is they don't
have one brand of minimalism they speak
and write broadly enough that you can
take their comments and mold them to
your situation and get genuine value
from it I love reading things like this
because that is so true there is no one
way to be a minimalist and Josh and I
are not proselytizing on how everyone
should be living their lives we are
simply sharing a recipe that has worked
for us and and I I think any good person
if they take a recipe they want to make
it their own and add their own
ingredients and they might keep a lot of
our ingredients in there but certainly
you know with Leo he's going to have a
lot different ingredients in his
minimalist lifestyle than we are you can
adjust it to your own personal tastes if
you're an extrovert if you're an
introvert if you want to travel around
the world if you want to be location
independent if you want to live in a big
city if you want to live in rural
Montana you know you can pretty much do
whatever you want and sharing our recipe
allows you to have the ingredients and
sequence that we used and then you can
adjust it as little or as much as you
want to suit your life the last part of
the reader comments we would usually
play a reader voice mail for you right
now so if you have a voice mail for us
you can simply give us a call so if you
have a question or a comment 406 - 1 9 7
8 3 9
and of course we'll send some
autographed books to some of our
favorite questions and favorite comments
but because this is our very first
podcast we don't have any reader
comments at this point let's move on to
our added value segment this is a each
podcast Ryan and I will talk about
something that is currently adding value
to our lives and generally will have
very little to do with minimalism it'll
just be something that we are currently
finding value in and there's a podcast
I'm listening to I listen to with
regularity it's called the culture gap
fest it's with the folks at Slate they
produce this and if three individuals
there and they share recommendations at
the end of their podcast so that's the
reason I'm recommending this now is
that's the eye where I got the idea for
recommendations they call it
endorsements but that is really adding
value to my life right now I don't
really stayed that connected with pop
culture these days I mean we moved to
Montana and I don't have internet or TV
at home and so I don't necessarily stay
heavily connected to pop culture but
this podcast is one way for me to
continue to understand of popular
culture but in a way that is
entertaining and a way that I find value
yeah for me I I'm going to give a shout
out to dogwood coffee since we were
talking about the Keurig earlier and
talking about coffee I was just in
Minneapolis and picked up some some
beans there and man they are just a
really well-crafted roastery
independently run ran independently ran
and they do an amazing job and I think
that they should totally go to get a
shout out you can order coffee online
they're not paying me to say this I
promise yeah I think you just google the
name dogwood kombu dogwood coffee and
you can order they get an Ethiopian
right now and I think of Guatemalan
that's really really good if phenomenal
coffee and we always joked last last
tour that we were on that we were it was
just an excuse to be on a coffee tour
all over the world we did eight
countries and and we even wrote an
article for Elle magazine about our
favorite coffee shops coffee roasters
and dogwood was was definitely on that
list
and so yeah check them out if you love
great coffee you'll probably find a lot
of value and that I just appreciate when
someone has a craft and that they put
their passion into it and it really
comes through a dogwood absolutely well
as always if we could leave you and this
podcast with one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks a lot
guys
all right folks that's it for today's
episode Ryan do you want to read the
script yes this podcast was produced by
Sean Harding our theme music was written
and performed by Peter Doran for more of
Peters music visit the minimalist comm
slash Peter if you have a question or a
comment for the minimalists give us a
call at four zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine that number again is
four zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or post your question on
social media using the hashtag ask the
minimalists we'll see you next time see
you every little thing you think that's
me every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it every little thing
that you got ahead every little thing
that you guys you gotta reach for and
you got a grand oh I bet that you'll be
fine without you so che your tea